[Music]
so the rumors true are you really
leaving oh oh you tell me you claim to
know everything
if pitch star Ali Larter really is in
the know our favorite Fox drama will be
coming back for a second season by
sixteen whispers yeah
yeah it's looking promising looking good
Wow looking really good that I signed on
to that at the last minute I was trying
to take some time off and then again you
know this really special project comes
and there's something really wonderful
about being able to be in a real
family-friendly positive show with
really interesting characters um but
don't underestimate Emilia that girl
that girl kicks butt in her own way I
know and where did she go I think she's
sitting in Cabo right now okay so
sipping margaritas your job is to take
ten percent of my income and do what I
asked you to do when are you gonna
realize once and for all that it's not
all about you what is the status of her
and Jenny do you think they're gonna
patch things up when I think about
Amelia she put everything she had in
Jenny and that's a lot of pressure for
anyone to handle I also think that Ginny
took a lot of bad advice and maybe drank
some of her own kool-aid a little bit so
you know I think a little bit time apart
isn't a bad thing
um but I definitely could see Amelia
just like going okay I need to
reevaluate my life yes seven Sheila's in
so she's laying on the beach in Cabo
you know the Beeching you have an early
flight
you know the fans on the internet are
just waiting for that Ginni Mike hookup
you see it happening I think it's early
you can't put them together too soon so
it's really fun to tease it but to give
up the sugar too easily it's like you
know can't get down on a first date
oh you're making us wait I'm so excited
so we should stay tuned yeah fingers
crossed fingers crossed
awesome
you